hello everyone so in the previous part
of the lecture we handed after the
relationship between Sigma X - x - and
Sigma xx Sigma YY and tau XY using the
force balance along the X direction so
what we are going to do next is carry
out the force balance in the Y -
direction to obtain a relationship
between tau X dash y dash and Sigma xx
Sigma YY and tau XY again so let's do
that first of all I will have to draw
the figure again so very quickly and
through try to do that so the vertical
edge first present
this would be Sigma xx
don't explain
Sigma YY
now explain
so I'll carry out my force balance now
Sigma f y dash is equal to zero just as
I had done earlier I'm going to consider
my edges LM MN and Ln let me defecate
here quickly so this was L m and and
we remember that Ellen had the area a
and M had the area a cos theta and L n
sorry MN and the area a sine theta
so first of all considering the
considering the face LM and first of all
considering the force associated with
the stress components Sigma X X which is
this so we write that as Sigma xx LM has
the area a cos theta we write that down
quickly now this force is directed along
X and we need to take the component of
it along the y dash direction so you'll
note here that the direction I'm
interested in so maybe we need to try
that parallel to y dash
so this angle
you note that
this is my X direction this is my Y
direction and this is my angle theta so
this angle was theta which means this
angle is 90 degrees minus theta so this
is cos of 90 degree minus theta that is
sine theta
that is
along the wide - direction
let us write down the contribution from
the Tau XY
the Dow XY that is lying on the edge LM
so this is tau XY again a cos theta so
we are considering this particular force
and we have to take the component of it
along the y - direction so this force
itself the tau XY e cos theta is along y
direction we have to take it along the Y
- direction parallel to the widest
direction so
we are actually considering this angle
so that's theta
No
for the first time as well as for this
job I have not written down the signs so
let's check what should be the sign so
for the first term that is considering
the Sigma xx e cos theta sine theta
again this is along the y dash direction
so this actually comes with a positive
sign however the second term which I
have just written down here the Tau XY a
cos theta cos theta that is along the
negative y dash direction so it should
come with a minus sign here next we
consider the edge MN the phase MN and we
consider the force associated with the
stress component Sigma YY so Sigma YY x
a sine theta which comes from the area
of the face MN
and we have to take the component of
this force along this direction which is
the Y - direction and that angle is
Theta
so that is cos theta but this is along
the negative Y direction so the negative
Y - direction rather so this is with a
minus sign next we consider the force
associated with this tau XY which is on
MN so we write that again tau XY area of
MN is is sine theta and the contribution
or the component of that force along the
Y - direction we have to consider this
angle which is actually 90 degrees minus
theta so that is cos of 90 degree minus
theta so that's sine theta but that
happens to be along the positive Y
direction so it is a plus just like the
first term involving Sigma xx and
finally let us not forget the phase L n
for which we have to consider the
contribution from the tau X dash y dash
that is
this one which is entirely along the Y -
direction so now X dash y dash x a which
is the area of the face Ln and since it
is entirely along the y dash we don't
have to take any component so that is
equal to zero so that is of course with
a plus sign so all in all what we'll
have after cancelling out the common
coefficient a Tau X dash y dash is equal
to minus Sigma xx
cos theta sine theta plus Sigma YY sine
theta cos theta
Plus tau XY cos square theta minus tau
XY sine square theta
all right so we can simplify it a little
bit further
Dow X dash y dash is equal to minus
Sigma X X cos theta sine theta that's
Sigma YY sine theta cos theta plus tau
XY taken as common cos square theta
minus sine square theta
okay
so if we look at the last bit of the
previous part of our lecture we had
obtained an expression for Sigma X - X -
and now we have obtained an expression
for tau x - y -
so let us collect these two expressions
and write them together
so we just repeat this expression Sigma
X dash X dash
and tau x - y - from here so just
rewriting it here
all right
so what we can do is we can use the
trigonometric identities which we are
familiar with from our high school maths
and rewrite the Sigma X dash X dash as
so we are obtaining it from here
so this will be 1 plus cos 2 theta by 2
plus Sigma YY 1 minus cos 2 theta by 2
and this one is simply sine 2 theta so
if we rearrange it what we'll obtain is
Sigma xx plus Sigma Y by 2 plus Sigma xx
minus Sigma YY by 2 cos 2 theta plus tau
XY sine 2 theta
so this is our expression for Sigma X -
X - we'll number this as our equation 1
next we would like to do a similar sort
of rearrangement for our tau x - y -
where we note that this can be easily
simplified the first two terms
and this is simply
of course to theta so
we'll call this as equation 2
note that although we have obtained
expressions for Sigma X - annex - and
tau X Dash and y dash we have not really
worked out what should be the expression
for Sigma y - y - but we don't really
don't have to get into the details of it
because you know that because our Y - y
dash is it's just rotated from the X -
by 90 degrees we can simply obtain the
expression for Sigma Y - y - by
replacing theta by theta plus 90 degrees
that's all we have to do so very quickly
we can obtain that expression for Sigma
Y - y - replace theta by
teacher plus ninety degree
in the expression of Sigma X - X - so
all that you have to do is good one
soon this equation one we just
so
that is 180 degrees XY
so over what we have is Sigma xx Sigma
YY I do - Sigma xx
scooti done
explain
so this will numbers equation three so
these are the our expressions for Sigma
X dash X dash Sigma y dash y dash and
tau X dash y dash alright